Imágenes como esta del campo de concentración en Auschwitz
quedaron grabadas en nuestra consciencia durante el siglo XX
y nos han dado un nuevo entendimiento de quiénes somos
de donde venimos y de la época en que vivimos.
Durante el siglo XX atestiguamos las atrocidades
de Stalin, Hitler, Mao, Pol Pot, Rwanda y otros genocidios
y a pesar de que el siglo XXI sólo tiene siete años de edad
ya hemos presenciado un genocidio en curso en Darfur
y los horrores cotidianos en Iraq.
Esto nos condujo a una concepción común de nuestra situación
que es que la modernidad nos ha traído una violencia terrible y que quizás
los pueblos nativos vivían una armonía de la que nos hemos apartado
poniéndonos en peligro. Este es un ejemplo
de un artículo sobre el Día de Gracias en el Boston Globe
de hace dos años donde el autor escribió: "La vida indígena
era difícil, pero no existían problemas de empleo
la armonía en la comunidad era fuerte, el abuso de sustancias
era desconocido, el crimen casi inexistente; las guerras entre tribus
eran en gran parte ritualistas y rara vez resultaba en una indiscriminada
y completa masacre". Todos conocen este sentimentalismo.
Lo enseñamos a nuestros hijos, lo oímos en la televisión
y en libros de historias. El título original de esta sesión era:
"Todo lo que sabes está equivocado" y presentaré evidencia
de que específicamente esta noción común está equivocada:
que nuestros ancestros eran mucho más violentos que nosotros
que la violencia ha ido declinando en amplios períodos de tiempo
y que hoy quizás vivimos en la era mas pacífica de la existencia de la especie.
de la existencia de nuestra especie. Ahora, en la década de Darfur y de Iraq
una afirmación como esa podría calificarse entre alucinatoria
y obscena. Pero voy a intentar convencerlos
de que este panorama es correcto. El declive de la violencia
es un fenómeno fractal. Pueden verlo a lo largo de milenios
de siglos, a lo largo de décadas y de años
aunque parece haber habido un punto de inflexión al inicio
de la Edad de la Razón en el siglo XVI. Se puede ver
por todo el mundo aunque no de manera homogénea.
Es muy evidente en Occidente empezando con Inglaterra
y Holanda alrededor de la era de la Ilustración.
Permítanme llevarlos a un viaje en varias potencias de 10
de la escala por milenios a la escala por años
para tratar de persuadirlos. Hasta hace 10,000 años todos los humanos
vivieron como cazadores-recolectores, sin asentamientos
y sin gobierno. A este estado comúnmente se le ha pensado
como uno de armonía fundamental. Pero el arqueólogo
Lawrence Keeley, observando la tasa de decesos
en los cazadores-recolectores actuales; eso constituye la mejor fuente
de evidencia sobre esta forma de vida, muestran una conclusión diferente.
Esta es una gráfica que el construyó
mostrando el porcentaje de muertes en varones debido a la guerra
en un número de sociedades forrajeras o cazadoras y recolectoras.
Las barras rojas corresponden a la probabilidad de que un hombre
muera a manos de otro hombre, en comparación a fallecer
por causas naturales en varias sociedades forrajeras de las
Tierras Altas de Nueva Guinea y del bosque tropical del Amazonas.
Varían entre una tasa de casi el 60% de probabilidad de que un hombre muera
a manos de otro hombre. En el caso de los Gebusi
sólo un 15% de probabilidad. La barrita azul en la esquina inferior
izquierda señala la estadística correspondiente a los Estados Unidos
y Europa en el siglo XX e incluye todas las muertes a causa
de ambas Guerras Mundiales. Si la tasa de mortalidad por las guerras tribales
hubiese continuado en el siglo XX, habrían sido 2 mil millones los muertos, no 100.
También a la escala por milenio podemos ver
la forma de vida de civilizaciones tempranas como las descritas
en la Biblia. Y en esta supuesta fuente de nuestros valores morales
uno puede leer descripciones de lo que se esperaba en la guerra
tal como en el siguiente pasaje bíblico en Números 31.
"Y pelearon contra Madián como Jehová lo ordenó á Moisés
y mataron a todos los varones. Y Moisés les dijo:
¿Habéis reservado a todas las mujeres? Matad ahora todos los varones
entre los niños y matad también a toda mujer que haya conocido varón
carnalmente. Y todas las niñas entre las mujeres que no hayan conocido
ayuntamiento de varón os reservaréis vivas." En otras palabras
mata a los hombres, mata a los niños, si encuentras a unas vírgenes
puedes mantenerlas vivas para que puedas violarlas.
Pueden encontrar 4 ó 5 pasajes en la Biblia de esta índole.
También en la Biblia uno ve que la pena de muerte
era el castigo aceptado para crímenes tales como la homosexualidad
adulterio, blasfemia, idolatría, responderle a sus padres
(risas) y recoger leña en el Sabbath.
Bien, ajustemos los lentes de acercamiento
un orden de magnitud y veamos a una escala de siglos.
Aunque no tenemos estadísticas para la guerra durante
la Edad Media hasta la era moderna
sólo a partir de la historia convencional sabemos - la evidencia
ha estado siempre bajo nuestras narices - que ha habido una reducción
en las formas de violencia socialmente aceptadas.
Por ejemplo, toda historia social revelará que la mutilación y la tortura
eran formas de castigo rutinarias. El tipo de infracción
que hoy pagarías con una multa, en aquellos días resultaba en
que tu lengua o tus orejas fueran cortadas, tus ojos cegados
la amputación de una mano y así sucesivamente.
Existieron numerosas formas ingeniosas sádicas para la pena de muerte:
ser quemado en la hoguera, desentrañamiento, la rueda
desmembramiento mediante el uso de caballos y demás.
La pena de muerte era una sanción para una lista de crímenes no violentos:
criticar al rey, robar una hogaza de pan. El esclavismo, por supuesto,
era el método preferido para salvarse de trabajar y la crueldad era
una forma popular de entretenimiento. Quizás el ejemplo más vívido
fue la quema de gatos en la cual un gato era alzado
en un escenario y bajado en cabestrillo a un fuego
y los espectadores se morían de la risa mientras el gato, aullando de dolor
era quemado a muerte.
¿Qué ocurría en asesinatos uno a uno? Bien, hay buenas estadísticas
porque muchos municipios registraron la causa de muerte.
El criminólogo Manuel Eisner
rastreó en todos los registros históricos a lo largo de Europa
la tasa de homicidios en cada aldea, caserío, pueblo y condado
que pudo encontrar y los complementó
con datos de cuando las naciones comenzaron a llevar estadísticas.
Lo graficó en una escala logarítmica yendo de 100 muertes
por cada 100 mil personas por año, que era aproximadamente la tasa
de homicidios en la Edad Media. Y las cifras se desploman
a menos de un homicidio por cada 100 mil personas por año
en 7 u 8 países europeos. Entonces hay un ligero incremento
en los sesenta. Las personas que dijeron que el rock llevaría
a la declinación de los valores morales tenían algo de cierto.
Pero hubo una disminución de al menos dos órdenes de magnitud
en homicidios desde la Edad Media al presente y
el punto de inflexión ocurrió a principios del siglo XVI.
Pasemos a la escala por décadas.
De acuerdo con organizaciones no gubernamentales
que mantienen esas estadísticas, desde 1945 en Europa y América
ha habido un agudo descenso de las guerras entre estados
en disturbios mortales, masacres étnicas y en golpes militares
incluso en Sudamérica. A nivel mundial ha habido un agudo descenso
por muertes en guerras entre estados. Barras amarillas indican el número
de muertes por guerra por año desde 1950 al presente.
Y como pueden ver, la tasa de mortandad desciende de 65 mil muertes
por conflicto por año en los cincuenta, a menos de 2 mil decesos
por conflicto por año en esta década, tan horrenda como lo es.
Incluso en la escala por años se puede ver un descenso de la violencia.
Desde finales de la Guerra Fría han habido menos guerras civiles
menos genocidios; una reducción del 90% desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial
una inversión del número de homicidios y crímenes violentos de los sesenta.
Esto es de las Estadísticas Uniformes de Crímenes del FBI. Pueden ver
que la tasa de violencia es relativamente baja en los cincuenta y sesenta
y después remonta por varias décadas y comienza
un abrupto declive, comenzando en los noventa, hasta regresar
casi al nivel que fue alcanzado por última vez en 1960.
Presidente Clinton, si se encuentra aquí, gracias.
(Risas)
La pregunta es: ¿Por qué tantas personas están tan equivocadas
acerca de algo tan importante? Creo que hay varias razones.
Una de ellas es que hay mejores reportajes: La Associated Press
es mejor cronista de las guerras sobre la faz de la Tierra
que lo fueron los monjes del siglo XVI.
Hay una ilusión: Los psicólogos cognitivos sabemos que mientras más fácil sea
recordar instancias específicas acerca de algo
más alta será la probabilidad que te adhieras a ello.
Las notas que leemos en el diario con imágenes sangrientas
se graban en la memoria más que al escuchar sobre todavía más personas
muriendo en cama por su edad. Hay dinámicas en los mercados
de opinión y militancia: nadie jamás ha atraído observadores, militantes
o donantes diciendo:
"Las cosas parecen ir mejorando cada vez más".
(Risas)
Hay culpabilidad por nuestro trato a los pueblos indígenas
en la vida intelectual moderna y una falta de voluntad para reconocer
que pudiesen haber algunas cosas buenas en la cultura occidental.
Y por supuesto nuestro cambio de estándares puede superar al cambio
en comportamiento. Una razón por la que bajó la violencia
es que las personas se cansaron de la carnicería y crueldad de la época.
Ese es un proceso que pareciera continuar
pero si los estándares vigentes superan al comportamiento
las cosas siempre se verán más brutales que lo que hubieran sido
de acuerdo con estándares históricos. Hoy nos indignamos con razón
cuando pocos asesinos son ejecutados por inyección letal
en Texas después de 15 años de apelaciones. No consideramos
que hace un par de siglos quizá hubieran sido quemados
en la hoguera por criticar al rey después de un juicio
que duraba 10 minutos y de hecho, que eso se habría sido repetido
una y otra vez. Hoy vemos a la pena capital
como evidencia de lo bajo que puede caer nuestro comportamiento
en vez de lo alto que nuestros estándares se han elevado.
Bueno, ¿por qué ha declinado la violencia? Nadie sabe realmente
pero he leído cuatro explicaciones, todas ellas creo,
tienen cierto nivel de plausibilidad. La primera es: Quizás
Thomas Hobbes tenía razón. Él fue quien dijo
que la vida en estado natural era: "solitaria, pobre, sucia, brutal
y breve". Argumentó, no porque
los humanos tengan una primitiva sed de sangre
o un instinto agresivo o un imperativo territorial
sino por causa de la lógica de la anarquía. En un estado de anarquía
hay una tentación constante de invadir preventivamente a tus vecinos
antes de que ellos te invadan a tí. Recientemente Thomas Schelling
da la analogía del dueño de una casa que escucha un crujido
en el sótano. Siendo buen estadounidense, tiene una pistola
en su mesa de noche, saca la pistola y baja las escaleras.
Y ve nada menos que a un ladrón con una pistola en la mano.
Ambos están pensando:
"En realidad no quiero matarlo, pero él está a punto de matarme.
Quizás debería dispararle antes de que él lo haga
especialmente dado que, aún si él no quiere matarme
quizá ahora está preocupándose de que yo pudiese matarlo
antes de él me mate." Y así sucesivamente.
Los pueblos cazadores y recolectores piensan de esta manera
y con frecuencia atacan a sus vecinos por miedo a ser atacados primero.
Ahora, una forma de lidiar con este problema es la disuasión:
no atacas primero, pero tienes anunciada públicamente una política
de que tomarás represalias salvajemente si eres invadido.
El detalle es que esta política tiene
la propensión a que se descubra el engaño por lo que sólo funciona
si es creíble. Para hacerla creíble debes vengar todo insulto
y arreglar todas las cuentas, lo que lleva a ciclos de sangrientas vendetas.
La vida se vuelve un episodio de Los Soprano. La solución de Hobbes
el Leviatán, fue que si la autoridad para el uso legítimo
de la violencia era conferido a una única agencia democrática, un leviatán
entonces tal estado podía reducir la tentación de atacar
porque cualquier tipo de agresión sería castigado
dejando su utilidad en cero. Eso eliminaría la tentación
a invadir preventivamente por temor a ser atacado primero.
Y elimina la necesidad de un detonador de represalias
para que tu amenaza disuasoria sea creíble. Y por lo tanto, llevaría
a un estado de paz. Eisner, el hombre que graficó las tasas de homicidios
que no vieron en la diapositiva anterior
argumentó que el momento del declive de los homicidios en Europa
coincidió con el surgimiento de los estados centralizados.
Eso apoya un poco a la teoría del leviatán.
También la apoya el hecho de que hoy vemos estallidos de violencia
en zonas con anarquía: en estados fallidos, imperios colapsados
regiones fronterizas, mafias, bandas callejeras y demás.
La segunda explicación es que en muchas épocas y lugares
hay un sentimiento generalizado de que la vida vale poco.
En la antigüedad cuando el sufrimiento y la muerte temprana era común
vivirlos en carne propia, uno tenía menos remordimientos al inflingirlos
a otros. Y conforme la tecnología y la eficiencia económica hacen la vida
más larga y agradable, uno le da mayor valor a la vida en general.
Este fue un argumento del politólogo James Payne.
Una tercera explicación apela al concepto de "un juego de suma no-cero"
y fue delineado en el libro Nadie Pierde del periodista
Robert Wright. Wright señala que en determinadas circunstancias
la cooperación, incluyendo la no-violencia, puede beneficiar a ambas partes
en una interacción, tal como las ganancias del comercio entre dos partes.
sus excedentes y ambas salen ganando, o cuando dos bandos
deponen sus armas y comparten el llamado "dividendo de paz"
que resulta en que ambos no tendrán que estar peleando todo el tiempo.
Wright argumenta que la tecnología ha incrementado el número
de juegos de suma positiva en que los humanos tienden a meterse
al permitir el comercio de bienes, servicios e ideas
a grandes distancias o entre grupos más grandes de personas.
El resultado es que las otras personas se vuelven más valiosas vivas que muertas
y la violencia disminuye por razones egoístas. Como Wright lo expresó
"Entre las muchas razones por las que creo que no debemos bombardear
a los japoneses es que ellos construyeron mi minivan."
(Risas)
La cuarta explicación fue capturada en el título de un libro
llamado The Expanding Circle, por el filósofo Peter Singer
quien argumenta que la evolución legó a los humanos un sentido
de empatía: la capacidad de tratar los intereses de otros
comparándolos con los propios. Desafortunadamente, siempre
lo aplicamos solo a un estrecho círculo de amigos y familiares.
Las personas fuera del círculo son tratadas como infrahumanas
y pueden ser explotadas con impunidad. Pero en la historia
el círculo se ha expandido. Se puede ver como un registro histórico
expandirse a partir de la aldea, al clan, a la tribu
a la nación, a otras razas, a ambos sexos
y, de acuerdo al mismo Singer, algo que deberíamos ampliar
a otras especies vivas. La pregunta es
si esto ha ocurrido, ¿qué ha impulsado tal expansión?
Y existe un número de posibilidades. Círculos incrementales
de reciprocidad en el sentido que propone Robert Wright.
La lógica de la regla de oro: entre más pienses acerca de e interactúes
con otras personas, más te darás cuenta de que es insostenible
privilegiar tus intereses sobre los de ellas
al menos no si quieres que ellas te escuchen. No puedes decir
que mis intereses son especiales comparados con los tuyos
tanto como tampoco puedes decir que el punto en particular
en el que estoy parado es un lugar único en el universo
porque ocurre que estoy parado en él en ese preciso minuto.
También podría estar impulsada por el cosmopolitismo:
por historias, periodismo, memorias, ficción realista, viajes
y alfabetismo, los cuales te permiten proyectarte en las vidas
de personas que anteriormente habías tratado como infrahumanos
y también darte cuenta de la contingencia accidental de tu situación
en la vida; la sensación de que: "me podría haber pasado a mí".
Cualesquiera que sean sus causas, la disminución de la violencia
tiene profundas implicaciones. Debería preguntarnos no sólo ¿por qué
hay guerra? Sino también, ¿por qué hay paz?. No sólo
¿qué estamos haciendo mal? Sino, ¿qué hemos estado haciendo bien?"
Porque hemos estado haciendo algo bien
y de seguro sería bueno averiguar qué es.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Me encantó esa charla. Creo que muchos en esta sala dirían
que esa expansión de... lo que estabas diciendo
de la que Peter Singer habla, es impulsada sólo por la tecnología
por la mayor visibilidad del otro, y el sentimiento de que el mundo
por tanto se vuelve más pequeño. Es decir, ¿será cierto?
Steven Pinker: Mucha. Coincidiría tanto con la teoría de Wright
que nos permite disfrutar de los beneficios de la cooperación
en círculos cada vez más grandes. Pero también, creo que nos ayuda
a imaginar lo que sería ser alguien más. Pienso que cuando lees
esas horribles torturas que fueron comunes en la Edad Media piensas
cómo fue posible que las hicieran.
¿Cómo no pudieron sentir empatía con la persona
que estaban desentrañando? Pero claramente
en lo que a ellos se refería, este era un ser extraño
que no tenía sentimientos similares a los suyos. Cualquier cosa, creo
que nos haga más sencillo imaginar intercambiando lugares
con alguien más significa que incrementa tu consideración moral
hacia esa otra persona.
CA: Bien. Me encantaría que dueños de medios de difusión escucharan esto
en algún momento el año próximo. Creo que es muy importante. Muchas gracias.
SP: Un placer.